[Music]
we all know that Tony Stark is Iron Man
I am Iron Man but without the suit he's
just a genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist Tony Stark is rich enough
to be Iron Man but how much money does
it take to live the life although Tony
Stark and Iron Man are fictional
we looked into real world prices to find
out how much would it cost to be Iron
Man Tony Stark lives in a luxurious
cliffside Manor in Malibu California and
it is extraordinarily high tech Malibu
homes that size go for about 75 million
dollars now the closest thing in the
real world to Starks crazy mansion would
be Bill Gates's home in Medina
Washington it's a huge house with
similar voice-activated computers and
underwater music system heated floors a
private library and a 23 car garage
insurance companies have valued the home
at 147 million dollars and less adding
10 million dollars for Starks Malibu zip
code the stark tower in New York City
was based on the MetLife building in
Manhattan in real life billionaire
Donald Bren owns the building
which is valued at three billion dollars
add in the starch technology and we get
three billion two hundred fifty seven
million dollars the highest-paid
stylists in Malibu charge up to $1,000
for a haircut
so assuming Tony Stark gets a good shave
and haircut for that trademark goatee
once a month it comes to $12,000 less
that in some fancy suits Rolexes and
designer sunglasses that gets us to
$100,000 Jarvis is a supercomputer with
artificial intelligence that start
designed to control his suits and
mansion one of the fastest and smartest
computers in the world is the ke
computer in Japan it is capable of eight
quadrillion calculations per second and
cost 1.4 billion dollars to design and
develop Starks Jarvis uses a remarkable
amount of HUD virtual reality the
popular virtual reality tech Acula Swift
was recently acquired by Facebook for
two billion dollars add up those numbers
Plus Jarvis has a really cool accent
which is not cheap we get three point
five billion dollars Tony Stark's
Palladium core arc reactor doesn't
really exist so we can't figure out the
real price to make one however according
to online comic book encyclopedia Comic
Vine Tony Stark's arc reactor is capable
of 12 gigajoules per second and 16
million horsepower from
Harrison NASA's Space Shuttle is capable
of 37 million horsepower the space
shuttle Endeavour cost 1.7 billion
dollars it might be a bit of a stretch
to say the closest energy consuming
vehicle to Ironman suit in the real
world is the space shuttle but is this
good a guess as any will assign that
cost at 1.7 billion
1.7 billion dollars the research and
development of the Ironman suit in the
movies is actually pretty insignificant
Tony draws up the plans by himself and
built the first version in a cave with a
bunch of scraps in the real world
however putting together a research team
as smartest Stark would be quite
expensive military aerospace and weapons
engineers make about $120,000 per year
and a solid team would cost about two
million dollars a year now let's look at
the cost of high-tech aircraft a stealth
bomber plane like the Northrop Grumman
b-2 spirit plane is close to the
capabilities of Iron Man in terms of
flight speed weapons etc according to
the US Air Force the maintenance
Faculty's construction and spare parts
for this aircraft come to 2.13 billion
dollars per unit adding up those numbers
gets us to 2 billion 132 million dollars
to calculate the cost of all the
different Iron Man suits would be
impossible because they each have
different functions and capabilities to
find a real-world cost we're going to
take the cost of the most high-tech
aircraft a Northrop Grumman b-2 which
costs two point one three billion
dollars per craft and assign that cost
to each suit if each of the 42 suits is
two point one three billion that gets us
to 89 billion 460 million dollars these
numbers added up give us a grand total
of 100 billion 49 million one hundred
thousand dollars if anyone could afford
to be a superhero it would be Tony Stark
[Music]
you